it's 1930 and Bobby Jones atlanta winner of
the British Amateur Championship the British
Open and the American National Open is gunning
for his fourth triumph of the year the national
amateur crown the scene is interlocked in
Minnesota and no man has ever won all four
major golf trophies the Georgia barrister
has only to beat Eugene B Homans to set a
new record for amateur golfers from 1923
when he first won the National Open Jones
is dominated the golfing world at his victory
today climax is a series of tremendous golfing
achievements Golf Association president
Douglas give Jones is tournament awards
then mr. Jones I'd like to give you the medal
first your every winning
now championship today sir
Bobby Jones the fairways fair head
boy one of the real greats of golf